!
>> Brian: JANICE APP. CALLS YOU
PERSONALLY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DOUBLES DOWN ON
ANTI-COAL, ANTI-OIL AGENDA.
LET'S WELCOME HOST AND EXECUTIVE
PRODUCER OF HOW AMERICA WORKS IT
IS MIKE ROWE.
[APPLAUSE]
EVERY TIME YOU HEAR SOMEONE SAY
YOU GUYS AREN'T DRILLING, NO, NO
OUR PRODUCTION IS EXACTLY THE
SAME.
HE SAYS I'M FOR FRACKING WHEN HE
WAS TRYING TO GET ELECTED NOW
THAT HE HAS GOTTEN ELECTED.
HE LET OUT AS IF HE FORGOT THERE
WAS A LIVE AUDIENCE AND
MICROPHONE ON.
STOP DRILLING I PLAN ON STOPPING
ALL DRILLING.
HOW DOES THAT RESONATE WITH
PEOPLE IN THE OIL AND GAS FOR A
LIVING.
>> I SUSPECT THEY FIND IT
ANNOYING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> ON A PRACTICAL LEVEL IT'S
JUST BAD NEWS FOR YOUR PERSONAL
ECONOMY BUT ON A MACROLEVEL FOR
THE COUNTRY, AND I CAN'T SPEAK
FOR ANYBODY BUT ME, IT'S JUST
ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS
WHERE WE EITHER HAVE TO TAKE
SOMEBODY AT THEIR WORD OR WE
HAVE TO WAIT FOR SOME SORT OF
INTERPRETIVE DANCE TO EXPLAIN
WHAT IT MEANT OR WE HAVE TO JUST
READ THE TEA LEAVES AND I THINK
THE PATIENCE THAT WE USED TO
HAVE FOR DOING THAT IS PROBABLY
GONE.
>> Ainsley: WE'RE SICK OF IT.
FETTERMAN HAS SAID HE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN FOR FRACKING, MEANWHILE,
MORATORIUM ON FRACKING.
JOE BIDEN TAKING AWAY THE JOBS
WHEN HE CLOSED DOWN THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE.
NOW HE WANT TO SHUT DOWN THE
COAL INDUSTRY AND NOT DRILL
ANYMORE.
HOW DOES THAT RESONATE WITH THE
VOTER IN WEST VIRGINIA?
WHEN JOE MANCHIN SAYS HE OWES
HIS PEOPLE AN APOLOGY NOW?
>> I THINK THERE IS ONLY ONE
RATIONAL WAY TO EXPLAIN IT.
AND I THINK IF YOU GENUINELY,
TRULY BELIEVE THAT THE WORLD IS
REALLY AND TRULY COMING TO AN
END IN 12 YEARS, AS WE HAVE BEEN
TOLD BY A LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> Brian: EVERY 12 YEARS.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE'RE COMING OUT OF THAT
CYCLE AGAIN BAD NEWS,
ARMAGEDDON.
SO YOU -- IF YOU REALLY AND
TRULY BELIEVE THAT, THEN CAN YOU
GET AWAY WITH SAYING THINGS LIKE
THAT IF DINED OF JUST PUNTS IT
DOWN THE HALLWAY.
NOW WE HAVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
IS THE WORLD REALLY COMING TO
ANNUAL END?
BECAUSE IF WE CAN'T ANSWER THAT
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE MY GUESS IS
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP HAVING
BIZARRE CONVERSATIONS WHERE
WORDS DON'T MEAN WHAT WE THOUGHT
THEY MEANT.
LIKE THAT SCENE FROM A PRINCESS
BRIDE.
YOU KEEP USING THAT WORD I DON'T
THINK IT MEANS WHAT YOU THINK IT
MEANS IT'S CONFUSING.
>> Steve: WE HAVE QUESTIONS FROM
THE FOLKS GATHERED HERE TODAY.
KEVIN IS RIGHT OVER THERE.
KEVIN, GOOD MORNING TO YOU,
WHAT'S YOUR QUESTION FOR
MR. ROWE.
>> MIKE, WE ALL LOVE YOUR SHOW.
YOU ARE NUMBER ONE WHEN IT COMES
TO CLEANING UP DIRTY MESSES.
YOU JUST A LITTLE BIT OF FUN AND
SERIOUS HERE, IF YOU WERE
PRESIDENT WITH A WOULD YOU CLEAN
UP IN THE SWAMP FIRST?
>> LOOK, I'M WAY OUT OF MY
LEAGUE, BROTHER, BUT, FOR
STARTERS, I WOULD SAY WHAT WOULD
IT LOOK LIKE IF WE ENFORCED THE
LAWS THAT WERE ON THE BOOKS?
JUST FOR STARTERS.
[APPLAUSE]
WHAT IF WE TAKE A BREATH AND
SAY.
>> Brian: NO MORE SMASH AND
GRABS AND ENFORCE THE BORDER?
ANTI-SMASH AND GRAB.
>> I'M ANTI-ANTI-CONSEQUENCE.
WHEN PEOPLE LOOK AT SOMETHING
LIKE A SMASH AND GRAB WHICH IN
THE SCHEME OF THINGS IS NOT A
BIG DEAL.
IN THE SCHEME OF THINGS,
WHATEVER, BUT WHEN YOU SEE THAT
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN OVER
AND OVER AND YOU SEE PEOPLE
GETTING AWAY WITH IT AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND AGAIN, RIGHT?
YOU CAN DRAW A STRAIGHT LINE TO
THAT TO THE NIGHTMARE ON THE
SUBWAY.
A STRAIGHT LINE FROM THAT TO ALL
SOURCE OF OTHER THINGS.
IT'S THE OLD BROKEN WINDOWS
THEORY I WOULD START BY SIMPLY
SAYING WE HAVE TO HAVE A
MECHANISM WHEREBY AMERICANS CAN
SEE THE CONSEQUENCES OF THE
THING UNFOLD AND IF WE DON'T
HAVE THAT, WE'RE JUST
GASLIGHTING OURSELVES.
>> Brian: WHAT IS ON HOW AMERICA
WORKS TONIGHT AT 8:00?
>> TONIGHT IS ARMY, WE WILL BE
IN FORT CARSON HOW AMERICA WORKS
NOW EVERY MONDAY NIGHT.
IT'S SO EASY TO FORGET.
VETERANS DAY IS THIS FRIDAY.
IT'S RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
THE ELECTION KIND OF SNUCK UP ON
US.
SO, WE'RE GOING TO CELEBRATED
ALL THINGS ARMY TONIGHT FOX
BUSINESS 8:0